ah ah this is a toughy
I studied AP US history for an entire
school year now I'm interested to see if
that was worth it or like a total waste
of a year of my life
I read that like test prep book like
three times odds of being able to watch
a movie during that class are always
much higher than most other classes
which I appreciate it I did okay on the
AP test at the end of the four but in
the class I think I got a C AP US
history was a push as the kids called it
one of the worst decisions I've ever
made in my life so I feel like this is
going to go probably not so well hmm
okay what year was the Boston Massacre
I'm not very good with use that's
probably why I'm not gonna history I do
remember this massacre being referred as
the shot that rang around the world you
can put a lower third saying how wrong I
am
1769 60 percent confident yay oh my god
yay okay damn it I was only one year off
which would be impressive if it wasn't
multiple-choice the Federalist Papers
were written by Alexander Hamilton James
Madison and ku okay it's either John
Hancock or John Adams I think because I
recognize those names of John Hancock
can do [ __ ] except write his name really
big I'm not upset that I don't know this
because of a push I'm mad I don't know
this because I listen to Hamilton I'm
gonna go with John J I got it right
yay I love this this is the best five on
the test you're gonna get none of these
right the Trail of Tears forestry
location of each tribe leading to the
deaths of thousands of Native Americans
I don't think it was the Sioux the super
pretty North yeah can I have a lifeline
Cherokee yes hey got a second question
Ryan I feel especially bad about this
one because I actually did a report on
the Cherokee in elementary school
what is the Fourteenth Amendment god
this is probably a really important one
I could probably figure it out better if
I knew what the 11th 12th and 13th floor
but I also don't know that oh yeah
that's the abolition of slavery
I hope son of a [ __ ] why wasn't that
earlier okay complete how are the best
is I'm gonna do better it's gonna be
fine I got this what does this political
cartoon best represent we got like an
Uncle Sam guy unlike some sort of
hemisphere with a hat and like a bowl
and some other three guys in the
background I mean I know what this is
saying but I don't know what idea this
is representing that doesn't make any
sense if you like its manifest destiny
or a social Darwinism it just sounds
right but this has got to be the Monroe
Doctrine which is like protecting
everything in our sphere of influence
whew Ida Tarbell is a famous example of
the terms all sound familiar but I don't
remember what any of them mean sounds
like pretty pointless to have that
knowledge in my head of just remembering
what the words sound like muckraker I
don't remember what a muckraker is can I
know what a muckrakers what's the more
Freaker what's a muckraker none of these
people know either it's not just me oh I
know that's Brown versus Board of
education and rivers what court case I
mean I know this woman
I can't even narrow it down oh man I'm
laughing because the answer I know none
of the answers I'm gonna go with Marbury
V Madison oh my gosh
wait I'm done i memorize all these facts
and I remember I thought it was really
important now I'm like I don't know how
important it was anymore
I came here thinking I was gonna get
every single question wrong and I got
most of the questions wrong but I at
least I got like a few correct I wanted
to do better I thought I knew more I had
no study prep time and I am old
by
[Music]